[Musique]
c'est la patrie c'est le drapeau il faut
respecter on est chez nous voilà on do
rempl les stades en orange blanc et
[Musique]
vert
on s'est dit ben avec le prix les
clients n'allaient pas rechercher ce
maillot mais actuellement ce maillot est
devenu une denrée très rare le maillot
original de la Côte d'Ivoire il se vend
très bien depuis le début de la canne on
a vendu près de 4000 à 5000 maillots
et ben on essaie de satisfaire les
clients du mieux qu'on
peut
on a mis en fait en avant un maillot qui
met en valeur notre patrimoine qui fait
la promotion de de la culture ivoirienne
par exemple vous pouvez voir ça c'est le
stade Félix qui a été rénové on a la ST
à kwaba et donc sur ce maillot vous avez
tout ce patrimoine là que nous offrons à
nos
[Musique]
visiteurs fa mieux prendre les maillots
officiels pourquo bah ça aide tout le
monde il y a des gens qui travaillent a
la FIF qui va gagner une pourcentage qui
pourra augmenter aussi on va dire le
budget de l'équipe nationale ils
pourront mieux acheter des
infrastructures des équipements voilà
sil gagne pas tu achètes un maillot à ce
prix tu gagnes pas bah non ça fait un
peu mal mais après c'est par l'amour du
foot pour l'amour du foot on est prêt à
faire des folies comme on
dit
a ma des pauvres des
riches pas un prix
fixil
10000 15000
aussi donc ça
dépend Gorter n pas les moyens
connaiss c'est la f il faut que tout le
monde
particip
[Musique]